isn't even there because it will never
push forward whereas black
does have the potential long term later
in the game to push this pawn forward
and open things up but david is there
something something's bad happened
because i don't think
my mother is calculated because i think
the knight can come in
okay and then you see on nakamura's face
as well yes
big blunder by madurov i think the
knight will just
attack the queen and then and then rook
takes rook it's about to be game over
white's knight jumping forward attacking
this queen but also
trying to jump into this square giving
check to the king and to the rook mama
jorov he's missed this move he's just
completely
uh well that's just blindness uh chest
blindness at its best
um double attack here the knight trying
to get these two and if the queen drops
back
the problem is you distract the queen by
taking this rook and after queen takes
rook
check and a fork black is about to lose
a rook for a night
let's go back to the player's cameras
because mama jarov he
must be looking at this position in
horror right now
this is a gift for hikaru an absolute
dream you know it's not often that